in this video you're going to learn the
basics behind sequences in series so
let's dive into this lesson so the first
thing we want to talk about is what
exactly is a sequence and what exactly
is a series well a sequence is basically
a list and you can see that the terms
are separated by a comma and that's
exactly what a sequence is whereas a
series okay is actually a sum where
you're adding the terms together so
let's look at this first sequence here
we have we've got five we've got nine 13
17 21 dot dot dot this goes on forever
and ever but we want to talk about first
is a little bit about the terminology so
this term here we call N equals 1 okay
for the first term and then this one
here is N equals 2 N equals 3 etc but
the value of the term we refer to that
as a sub 1
see how that's like a little bit lower
it's a subscript like Submarine a little
bit below the line and then this year
number 9 is a sub 2 it's the value of
the second term 13 is a sub 3 it's the
value of the third term etc so that's a
little bit about the notation now let's
say we wanted to find a set of terms in
a sequence and we say well let's just
maybe find the first 5 terms
well we're given here as we're given a
rule or a formula in order for us to
find those terms so here we have a sub 1
okay that means N equals 1 that's the
first term so what we're gonna do is
wherever we see an we're gonna put 1 in
place of N and then we're gonna multiply
by 3 and subtract 4 so 3 times 1 is 3
minus 4 equals negative 1 a sub 2 we're
gonna put 2 in for n that's going to be
3 sub 2 minus 4 that's 6 minus 4 which
equals to a sub 3 again we're just
putting 3 & 4 n that's going to be 9
minus 4 which is equal to 5 mmm a sub 4
we're putting foreign for n 3 times 4 is
12 minus 4 is how much that's 8 and then
if we do a sub 5 3 times 5 minus 4 is 15
minus 4 which equals 11 so now what I
want to show you is say we go ahead and
plot these points so what this
represents is the first term is negative
1 so over here at 1
we're down here at negative one the
second term is two so I'm going to go to
and up two and the third term is five so
that's going to be three that's one two
three four five and you can see it's
continuing at that same constant rate
and what you can notice here is that
this really looks like the equation of a
line it looks like y equals MX plus B M
is like our slope you can see three and
you can see each of these is going up by
three each time so when you're adding
the same quantity each time we call that
an arithmetic sequence and I'm going to
talk about that a little bit in another
video that I'll direct you to at the end
of this video but that's the key this is
graphing a sequence and we don't want to
draw a line through these points this is
actually like a discrete meaning these
are separate there's not like a point
one like a one and a half term or 1.75
term it's just integer values like term
1 2 3 4 exercise let's look at another
example so this one here we've got a sub
N equals 2 to the N power plus 1 how do
we find the first five terms in this
sequence well we're gonna follow that
same pattern we did in the last problem
we take a sub one
remember N equals 1 that just tells us
that this is the value of the first term
but wherever we see n we're gonna put 1
so that's gonna be 2 to the first power
plus 1 of course 2 to the first is 2
plus 1 equals 3 the second term we're
going to now put 2 in Firenze so 2
squared is 4 plus 1 equals 5 the third
term we have 2 cubed plus 1 that's a
plus 1 which equals 9 the fourth term we
have 2 to the fourth plus 1 that's 16
plus 1 is 17 and then for the fifth term
2 to the fifth plus 1 is equal to 33 so
let's go ahead and plot these points I
want to show you the pattern here the
first term is 3 so that's going to be
right about here the second term is 5 so
that's going to be right about here the
third term is 9 okay which is right
about here and fourth term is 17 which
is somewhere around here I'm counting by
fives on the y-axis the fifth term is at
33 which is somewhere right around here
now
you'll notice on this one see how that
variable is in the exponent position
this is an exponential function so you
can see it's growing faster and faster
like that and so this one is not
arithmetic it's not geometric geometric
is when you're multiplying by the same
number each time to get to the next term
in the sequence but you can see it's not
like we're adding the same thing each
time that would be arithmetic we're not
multiplying by the same number each time
that would be geometric so this falls
into what we call like an either
category and in the follow-up video to
this lesson I'm gonna get into the
details of how to work with those
different formulas but first we want to
set the groundwork here in this lesson
okay switching gears are talking about
series now a series is a sum right so
you're adding all these terms together
and that represents the sum of the
series but when we talk about writing a
series in summation or Sigma notation
what does that mean well Sigma this is
the Greek letter Sigma right here and it
just means like some like you're adding
up all the terms together so what we're
gonna do is we're gonna find the sum of
this series here and I want to show you
little bit about the notation so we
already talked about how this is the sum
this is the index here see how I equals
1 and what you do is you put one in for
I and you find that value of that term
and then you work your way up
sequentially like consecutively until
you get to this top number here so we're
going to put one in then two and then
three and then four and all the way up
to five and we're going to add up all
those terms so let's go ahead and do
that so if I put one in here two times
one is two plus three is equal to five
if I put the next number okay which is
two that's gonna be two times two is
four plus three is seven if I put three
in there 2 times 3 is 6 plus 3 is 9 if I
put 4 in there that's 2 times 4 is 8
plus 3 is 11 and if I put this top
number in here 5 2 times 5 is 10 plus 3
is 13 and again remember the Sigma means
sum so we're actually adding up all
these terms together so let's see 5 plus
7 is 12 12 plus 13 is 25 9 plus 11 is 20
so 20 plus 25 that's 45 so that
represents the
some of this series so this is just a
way of like writing the series in a more
compact form instead of having to write
out all of these terms you can write it
in the summation notation now let's look
at another example let's look at number
four here what we're gonna do is we're
going to write this series here at the
top in summation notation so how do we
do that so we're kind of working
backwards to get to this form right here
so we're going to start off with our
Sigma and we're going to use our index
we're usually use a letter I or J or K
that's a typical you can use any letter
you want you just want to make sure that
these match okay that this is I this is
I and now what we need to do is we need
to figure out how many terms are there
one two three four five terms so this is
gonna be going from one to five but now
say for example this was like dot dot
dot like that so that means it keeps
going forever and ever and what we can
do is then we can use this infinity
symbol so we're going from the first
term to infinity and this means that
we're summing or adding up all the terms
but we need a formula or a rule for this
pattern here we haven't talked about the
formulas yet so what we're going to do
is let's just see if it can figure out
the pattern it looks like we're
subtracting three to get to the next
term next term next term so and you can
see because it's a constant decrease I'm
thinking linear I'm thinking like a line
and I'm thinking of a slope of negative
three okay
but if I put one in here I get negative
three times 1 is negative three but see
I'm actually getting nine so I need to
adjust for that I'm gonna add 12 let's
just check that out so negative 3 plus
12 that's 9 if I put 2 in here for the
second term that's negative 3 times 2 is
negative 6 plus 12 is 6 if I put 3 in
here that's negative 9 plus 12 is 3 okay
it looks like it's working out so it's
basically at this point we're kind of
having to be a little bit creative what
we're gonna get into the formulas in
that next video that I mentioned it
follows up for this video so if you want
you can put it in parentheses to treat
that like a group but this is again just
a compact way of writing this series so
follow me over to that video right there
where we really dive into a lot of
example problems the formulas finding
sums finding at particular terms etc
I'll see over in that video